hello here it's this kaufman
league title and i want to continue the series
i started on the seven secrets
of language learning
the first secret was to spend
enough time must to
be successful the second secret  it was to
do pleasant things things
that you like because
the learning will be more effective and
you will therefore want to spend the time
necessary to succeed
good the third secret is to pay
attention to what is happening in the
language to develop the ability
to realize what is happening in
the language
this is the case of course with regard to
pronunciation you have to listen well
you have to listen to what the
net finally says what the native says
this too  is the case with
regard to
the structures of the language of course there
are different ways of developing
this ability to realize
what is happening in the language that is
first of all the fact of  having read a lot and
listened a lot because at the beginning everything
is difficult everything is strange
everything is a little blurry and
as we listen and read
and learn bayer words things
that are now beginning  to get out only
when you start to realize
things that you did
n't realize before so a lot of reading a
lot of elbows it helps a lot
it's obvious that
grammar explanations can help but it's not
by reading the  grammar explanations
that we will immediately understand it is
not the case because when we do not have
enough reference points all the
explanations are very difficult but
it helps anyway it helps us a little
especially if we like  you do it myself
for example I reread
the leaders but each time not with
the intention of remembering what
I read but it seems to me it helps me to see
oh yes of course there it is
like that for example in the streets it's
like that q  ue is so good so from time
to time read a book saeed grammar
work and vocabulary flashes because
it's not because we go reading a
list or making flash cards that we
will remember all that  but it helps
we see a little the connections the
relations between different different
words and it is therefore it helps
so even if we write and we are
corrected well
it's not because we were
corrected in the evening by the invs in
activating what we are going to speak
correctly right away it is not the case but all
this helps us to notice
what is happening in the language and
finally it is the main asset
of someone  who is who who learns
languages ​​well is that hip hop where
she can independently begin to
notice what is happening take
note of what is happening in the moor and
each time against conchs we
pay attention and understand from what  what
happens it helps our brain is little by
little it becomes customs and
eve  ntually we can finally
express ourselves correctly well pronounce
correctly so and even for the
pronunciation sometimes it is useful to
record and listen to its
pronunciation and compare it with the
pronunciation of the natives that it
helps us to realize  of what happens
possibly it helps us so apart from
the most more correctly with finally g
8 g also a gram ita
grammatically is also a pronunciation point of view
here it is the third
secret thank you very much